christo fait parler de lui cristaux
c'est cet artiste américain qui emballe
les lieux publics
on en parle à berlin ils voulaient
carrément emballé le rail ce tact et les
allemands finalement n'ont pas l'air de
tout à fait d'accord ils ont trouvé que
c'était un peu irrespectueux
à paris en revanche la séance emballages
a déjà commencé le pont-neuf va être
recouvert à la manière cristaux mais il
ya fort à parier que ce sera comme
d'habitude
superbe alors de nombreux jeunes ont été
embauchés pour ce travail et l'opération
coûte cher c'est lui mario yves dreux
compte à rebours pour le projet le plus
fou de l'histoire de paris dans dix
jours ces jeunes gens seront les guides
qui vous expliqueront tout sur le
pont-neuf empaqueter par christo un
travail très convoité ils étaient là dès
l'aube pour se faire embaucher dans les
théâtres ont apparu
ce hors exceptionnels mais disons que
c'est une autre façon
pour le moment j'ai pas de culot et moi
je trouve ça plutôt intéressant ça m'a
rajeuni travail à matignon
pour la beauté du projet hausse
aulas
collectif
empaqueter le pont neuf qui ressemblera
cette maquette qu'est ce que ça veut
dire pourquoi comment à quel prix
pourquoi d'abord tous les artistes on a
peiné dessiner le pont neuf et l'a
interprété dans leur manière
pourquoi utiliser la toile de tente ou
christian le toit était grande
fascination pour milliers d'aînés dans
l'histoire de la série mon le preneur
une fois impacté au drapé enveloppait le
rendre en propulsion très
poétique et très nouvelles nouvelles
comme en face on se donne en état
positions différentes
jeudi par le pont neuf pas bien comme ça
mais pour 14 jours le pont neuf ce sera
une nouvelle dimension
et voici jeanne-claude la femme de
cristaux sa collaboratrice son ministre
des finances
coût de l'opération 18 millions de
francs minimum entièrement mais oui à la
charge de cristaux geste aux dépenses
pour ses projets de l'argent qui est à
lui et qui pourrait dépenser à n'importe
quoi d'autre il pourrait acheter des
diamants à sa femme il y cristaux fait
des dessins qui sont très beaux qu'ils
ont une valeur marchande beaucoup plus
élevés aujourd'hui qu'il ya 25 ans bien
sûr vend ses dessins au musée à des
galeries et à des collectionneurs privés
et avec l'argent nous le dépensons pour
notre plaisir
et notre plaisir c'est de faire des
projets christo christov pourquoi vous
ne voulez pas être subventionné vous
pourriez avoir de l'argent d'une
fondation
bien ministère et pourquoi pas vous
savez c'est même chose je disais déjà
avant que ces projets sont tous
commissionnaires à moi mais moi je suis
l'homme qui je décide qu est-ce qui vous
ferment je refuse de faire des gommages
je fais pas de quoi à financer les
projets ils ont un pouvoir les un côté
un peu souffert site qui comptait au
dernier moment on n'a pas six jours
prochains les toiles seront déployés
dimanche on pourra déambuler sur un pont
neuf tout neuf et bien plus tard on
pourra dire à ses petits enfants moi j'y
étais
[Musique]